Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
你好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件目前正在进行的激动人心的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“经常性收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。Lisa本人还会直接提供丰厚的奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢得与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导时间。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。我是Marianne Trent博士，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Thank you so much for listening. If you are listening to this when it's been released, then you might well know that it is currently January 2023. If you are yourself an aspiring psychologist, you might also know that January 2023 is quite an important month in terms of timeframes. Now, if you are not an aspiring psychologist please don't tune out because there's going to be loads of useful content in here for you and you might be like what not an aspiring psychologist? What do you mean? This is the Aspiring Psychologist podcast
我是Marianne Trent博士，是一名合格的临床心理学家。非常感谢你的收听。如果你是在节目发布时收听的，你可能知道现在是2023年1月。如果你自己也是一名有抱负的心理学家，你可能也知道，从时间框架来看，2023年1月是一个相当重要的月份。现在，如果你不是有抱负的心理学家，请不要离开，因为这里会有大量对你有用的内容。你可能会想：不是有抱负的心理学家？什么意思？这是《有抱负的心理学家》播客，
but everybody's welcome here. Let's be inclusive. Let's be friendly. I know that I've got lots of other disciplines listening as well, people who want to upskill their knowledge about working in mental health settings. So I've got people that work in social work, people that work in mental health nursing, people that work in care settings, in education settings, anybody that wants to have like a little insider sneak peek or to help think about some of these complicated and important issues that we discuss in the podcast. So do stay tuned because as you know there's always useful stuff in here but if you are an aspiring clinical psychologist or educational psychologist or someone else that's got interviews
但这里欢迎所有人。让我们保持包容和友好。我知道还有很多其他学科的人在收听，他们希望提升自己在心理健康领域工作的知识。所以我有很多从事社会工作、心理健康护理、护理环境、教育环境工作的人，任何想要获得一点内部见解，或者想要思考我们在播客中讨论的这些复杂且重要问题的人。所以请务必收听，因为如你所知，这里总是有有用的东西。但如果你是一位有抱负的临床心理学家、教育心理学家，或者是其他在春季有面试的人，
coming up for their specific sphere of psychology in springtime then this is going to be particularly useful for you so I know already I've seen on Twitter come on follow me on Twitter Dr Marianne Trent I've seen people talking about having been offered interviews for educational psychology but currently it's too early for NHS funded places to have been offered for interview what we do know is that the 31st of January 2023 is the deadline for Clearinghouse who sort out all the applications for the NHS funded and I think even some of the self-funded options that you will know what you've applied for. They sort out the applications and it's their job to have released all of the applications on or before the 31st of January 2023. So that means that the courses will definitely have your form to review by then, if you have indeed applied.
那么这对你来说将特别有用。我已经看到在Twitter上（快来关注我的Twitter：Dr Marianne Trent）有人在谈论收到了教育心理学的面试邀请，但目前NHS资助的名额面试邀请发放还为时过早。我们所知道的是，2023年1月31日是Clearinghouse的截止日期，他们负责处理所有NHS资助名额的申请，我想甚至包括一些自费选项，你应该知道你申请了什么。他们负责整理申请，他们的工作是在2023年1月31日或之前发布所有申请结果。这意味着到那时，如果你确实申请了，课程方肯定会收到你的表格进行审核。
However, of course, it may already have happened. But by that point, I think if I was in your position and when I was in your position, it would feel like a new level of, oh, it's like another step along with the process. So whilst we're talking dates, let me take you through the other key dates that we're going to be covering in this cycle of applications. So if your chosen university is using selection tests,
当然，这可能已经发生了。但在那个时间点，如果我是你，当我处于你的位置时，这会感觉像是进入了一个新的阶段，哦，这是流程中的又一步。所以，既然我们在谈论日期，让我带你了解一下我们在本轮申请周期中将涵盖的其他关键日期。因此，如果你们选择的大学使用选拔测试，
then I would imagine that you would be invited for those selection tests at any time from the start of February until March. The deadline for the courses to have let you know whether or not you have been shortlisted for interview this year is St Patrick's Day the 17th of March 2023. Now of course that might mean that you're offered an outright interview, it might mean that you're offered a reserve place interview, they don't always give you what place you are on the reserve list for interviews, or it might mean that you're given thanks but no thanks and I believe largely gone are the days that you get much information about
那么我想你应该会在2月到3月之间的任何时间收到选拔测试的邀请。课程方通知你今年是否入围面试的截止日期是2023年3月17日，即圣帕特里克节。当然，这可能意味着你直接获得了面试机会，也可能意味着你获得了候补面试名额（他们并不总是告诉你你在候补名单上的位置），或者可能意味着你收到了“谢谢，但不用了”的回复。我相信，你获得关于为什么没有入围的详细信息的日子已经一去不复返了。
why you weren't shortlisted. So that date is the 17th of March so you will know either way by the 17th of March so it's not super distance away but of course if you are applying to somewhere with selection tests you might want to think in more detail about this so there's more information coming up about those shortly too. This year the interviews across all of the courses for the NHS funded places for clinical psychology start from the 20th of March and finish on the 26th of May 2023. Now across all of the courses it's staggered so they're not all happening at the same time. Some courses offer one week, some courses offer two weeks and there might even be some offering more than that but they're usually staggered and they're usually pretty well staggered across geographical areas too. So I have never heard of anyone being offered interviews on the same day for different courses. I have heard of
所以那个日期是3月17日，无论如何你都会在3月17日之前知道结果，所以距离现在并不遥远。但当然，如果你申请的地方有选拔测试，你可能需要更详细地考虑这一点，所以很快会有更多关于这些测试的信息。今年，所有临床心理学NHS资助名额的课程面试从2023年3月20日开始，到2023年5月26日结束。在所有课程中，面试是错开的，所以它们不会同时发生。有些课程提供一周，有些提供两周，甚至可能还有更长的，但它们通常是错开的，而且在地理区域上也分布得相当好。所以我从未听说过有人在同一天收到不同课程的面试邀请。我听说过
people being offered interviews in the same week for different courses, which wasn't necessarily so problematic when they were all Zoom. I know a lot of them were in person last year, too. So, yeah, it will be wait and see time. I think there's some degree of organisation in what might look like chaos in the background to make sure that they're not calling candidates on the same day. Once all the interviews are released, you've been invited or not invited, there will be some compassionate Q&A sessions coming up from me too. The first of those will be happening with me on my socials and will take place on Monday the 13th of March 2023 starting at 7.30. The easiest place for you to find me there is to come and hang out on the Facebook group the Aspiring Psychologist Community
人们在同一周收到不同课程的面试邀请，当面试都在Zoom上进行时，这并不一定是个问题。我知道去年很多面试也是面对面的。所以，是的，这将是等待的时间。我认为在看似混乱的背景下，其实有一定的组织性，以确保他们不会在同一天召集候选人。一旦所有面试结果发布，无论你是否被邀请，我也会进行一些富有同情心的问答环节。第一次问答将于2023年3月13日星期一晚上7点30分在我的社交媒体上进行。找到我最简单的方法是加入Facebook群组“Aspiring Psychologist Community”，
brackets free group with Dr Marianne Trent. So that's how you can guarantee you won't miss that one that's the first one and the second of those will take place on Monday, the 17th of April 2023 at 7.30pm. And then in a change from our usual routine, we have the third and final one of the season on a Tuesday because we've got a bank holiday scheduled for Monday, the 1st of May. So we're having Tuesday, the 2nd of May at 7.30pm. So in case you want to get those dates in your diary, I'm giving you them early now. And of course, they will be available in the show notes as well. So the final dates to bear in mind is that if you are in the position, I was going to say a lucky position, but you might feel quite lucky. but if you are in the position where you are offered deep inside places, I don't think you're lucky.
（括号内：Dr Marianne Trent的免费群组）。这就是你如何保证不会错过那次活动，那是第一次。第二次将于2023年4月17日星期一晚上7点30分进行。然后，为了改变我们通常的惯例，我们本季度的第三次也是最后一次活动将在周二进行，因为5月1日星期一有公共假期。所以我们定在5月2日星期二晚上7点30分。如果你想把这些日期记在日记里，我现在提前告诉你。当然，它们也会在节目说明中提供。最后需要记住的日期是，如果你处于那个位置——我本来想说幸运的位置，但你可能会觉得很幸运——但如果你处于获得面试名额的位置，我不认为你是幸运的。
I think it's your time. You're ready for the next step. It's your time. You've done well. It's not luck. It's judgment. It's capability. It's achievement.
我认为这是你的时刻。你已经为下一步做好了准备。这是你的时刻。你做得很好。这不是运气。这是判断力。这是能力。这是成就。
It's accomplishment. It's confidence, it's, I don't know, eating your Weetabix before you go for your interview, making sure you're not hungry, it's making sure you don't do a wee in the middle of what you're saying so that you can think calmly. It's finding your, you know, your comfortable zone and your window of tolerance so that you can perform optimally. Not luck. There might be a sprinkling of luck in there um it's about feeling comfortable in what you're wearing it's about it's about so many things but i don't think it's about luck so yeah let's not let's not um invalidate ourselves
这是造诣。这是自信。我不知道，面试前吃点麦片，确保你不饿，确保你在说话时不会想上厕所，这样你才能冷静思考。这是找到你舒适的区域和你的耐受窗口，这样你才能发挥出最佳水平。不是运气。里面可能有一点点运气成分，但更多的是关于穿着舒适，关于很多很多事情，但我认为这与运气无关。所以，是的，让我们不要否定自己，
by thinking it's all luck because it's not you know even to get into these you've worked your bottom off to get there so So if you are in the position where you are offered places to train on one or more declined courses, although you can only do one at a time, then you need to have confirmed or declined those places by the 9th of June 2023. So other than reserveless places dropping in if people drop out, we should know where we're at by the 9th of June 2023. So what are we going to do now that we have an idea of the dates? How are we going to take this forward? How are we going to roll with it? How are we going to run with it? How are we going to find our comfortability how are we gonna find the energy to get
认为这一切都是运气，因为事实并非如此。你知道，即使是进入这些课程，你也付出了巨大的努力才走到这一步。所以，如果你处于获得一个或多个课程面试名额的位置（尽管你一次只能参加一个），那么你需要在2023年6月9日之前确认或拒绝这些名额。所以，除了如果有人退出而产生的候补名单名额之外，我们应该在2023年6月9日之前知道结果。既然我们对日期有了概念，我们现在要做什么？我们该如何推进？我们该如何应对？我们该如何坚持下去？我们该如何找到我们的舒适感，我们该如何找到能量来度过
through this recruitment phase which may end for you in March which may end for you in June which may you know end happily or with you know lots of complicated feelings what are we going to do what are we going to do so right now we're just going to take a breath we are going to tolerate that idea that this is coming this is happening and also we're going to perhaps have a little look at the application that you submitted we're not going to look at it with horror, we're just going to look at it and observe, just see what you said about yourself. You might well have heard it since you submitted it or put it in a drawer never to be looked at again, but it's useful
这个招聘阶段？它可能在3月结束，也可能在6月结束，可能以快乐的方式结束，也可能伴随着许多复杂的感受。我们该怎么办？所以现在，我们只是深呼吸，我们要容忍这个想法：这一切即将到来，正在发生。同时，我们或许可以稍微看看你提交的申请。我们不会带着恐惧去看它，我们只是观察它，看看你对自己说了些什么。你可能在提交后就没再看过它，或者把它放进抽屉里再也没看过，但它很有用，
to just think about how your skills might have changed, how things might become strengthened, whether things haven't changed in the way that you imagined by this stage when you applied. Just have a little look, just have a look, just be curious and notice as we say in EMDR and we're going to tolerate the idea that others are going to be looking at that. Others who do not know you personally, who don't, you know, don't know anything about you other than what you've put on your forms. They won't see your name, I believe that's redacted, but we're just going to tolerate the idea that people are going to be accessing that and reading that and just do our breathing and just tolerate that. Stay in our
可以思考一下你的技能是如何改变的，事情是如何变得更强大的，或者事情是否没有像你申请时想象的那样改变。稍微看一看，观察一下，保持好奇心，就像我们在EMDR中所说的那样。我们要容忍这样一个想法：其他人将会看到它。那些不认识你个人的人，除了你在表格上写的内容外，对你一无所知。他们看不到你的名字，我相信那是经过编辑的，但我们只需要容忍人们会访问和阅读它的想法，然后进行呼吸，容忍它。保持在我们的
window of tolerance whilst knowing that that's out there your baby is out there and we're also going to have a think about whether there are any areas where you could develop between now and when the interviews start could you think about strengthening your skills in research and that might look like practicing some on paper it might look like getting involved with research, it might look like going to research meetings. What could you do between now and depending on when your interviews for your courses are mid-May to strengthen your skills as a candidate? But of course we're not just thinking about between now and May because these things that you change, that you do, that you strive for right now will be with you forever. The things that I did at that point are still with me now.
耐受窗口内，同时知道它就在那里。你的“孩子”就在那里。我们还要考虑一下，在现在到面试开始之间，是否有任何领域可以发展。你能考虑加强你的研究技能吗？这可能看起来像是练习一些纸面工作，可能涉及参与研究，也可能涉及参加研究会议。在现在到5月中旬（取决于你的课程面试时间）之间，你能做些什么来加强你作为候选人的技能？当然，我们不仅仅是在考虑现在到5月之间，因为你现在所改变的、所做的、所追求的这些事情将永远伴随着你。我在那个阶段所做的事情至今仍伴随着我。
So they stay with you like little golden nuggets. Could you practice thinking about creating, discussing, holding in mind formulations for people? Could you do that? So let's ponder that as we go for a quick break here so have a listen to this little jingle and I'll be back on the other side to give you more top tips for what we could be doing between now and May to really help you bring the best possible chances of success. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective.
所以它们像小金块一样伴随着你。你能练习思考、创造、讨论、在心中保持对他人的构思吗？你能做到吗？所以让我们在休息时思考一下这个问题。听听这段小插曲，我回来后会给你更多建议，告诉你从现在到5月我们可以做些什么，来真正帮助你获得最大的成功机会。所以来看看吧。它就在这本书里。它是《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。
It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Boom. My clinical psychology journey just became more enjoyable with this book. Dr. Marianne understands the value of individual experiences in their professional development as a clinical psychologist and has elegantly collected a variety of valuable lessons from clinical psychologists of different backgrounds. You'll be sure to learn something from this and reflect on your own journey too. This book shows you that no matter where you are
它是《临床心理学家集体》。它是《临床心理学家集体》。砰。我的临床心理学之旅因为这本书变得更加愉快。Marianne博士理解个人经历在临床心理学家职业发展中的价值，并优雅地收集了来自不同背景的临床心理学家的宝贵经验。你一定会从中有所收获，并反思你自己的旅程。这本书向你展示了，无论你处于什么位置，
on your journey as a clinical psychologist, your personal development is never ending. That will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. welcome back thanks for listening so we were thinking before the break about whether you can strengthen your skills knowledge and expertise and confidence in formulating and talking about formulations. Something really key in psychology. And so that's something really useful that you can do. And this is something that might feel a bit cringy, this next one. Can you practice developing your
作为一名临床心理学家，你的个人发展是永无止境的。这将帮助你获得资格。所以来看看吧。它就在这本书里。它是《临床心理学家集体》。它是《临床心理学家集体》。欢迎回来，感谢收听。休息前我们正在思考你是否可以加强你的技能、知识、专业能力以及在构思和谈论构思方面的自信。这是心理学中非常关键的一点。所以这是你可以做的非常有用的事情。接下来这一点可能会让你觉得有点尴尬。你能练习发展你的
skills and confidence in talking about yourself out loud without cringing. And this is where your Zoom camera or your video camera or your phone camera comes in useful. Can you talk to yourself about yourself without wanting to run away and hide in a cave. I struggled with that actually. I think the first time I really tried to do that was a mock interview with my then supervisor and I was just cringing and dying a thousand deaths inside. But had I been more used to that earlier on, then I think that would have been a good thing so yeah give it a go nothing bad will happen if you say good stuff about yourself you know I think good stuff will come from that let's not have any um apprentices on currently we don't want any apprentice cv
在不感到尴尬的情况下大声谈论自己的技能和自信吗？这就是你的Zoom摄像头、摄像机或手机摄像头派上用场的地方。你能对自己谈论自己而不想要逃跑并躲进洞穴里吗？我实际上曾为此挣扎过。我想我第一次真正尝试这样做是在与我当时的导师进行模拟面试时，我感到非常尴尬，内心经历了无数次死亡。但如果我早点习惯这一点，我想那会是一件好事。所以，试一试吧，如果你说自己的好话，不会发生坏事。你知道，我认为好事情会随之而来。让我们不要有任何……目前没有学徒，我们不想要任何学徒简历
ripping to shred moments where we've said things are just not true you know so we want to be staying within our zone of competencies and stay accurate about what we're saying and what we've done but it's okay to talk about things in a client confidential nature that you've done and that evidence why you're going to be a great psychologist and why you are a great currently unqualified psychologist. And next if you are applying to a university that does have selection tests they might be logical sort of deductive reasoning tests there might be situational judgment tests then could you start thinking about planning out and practicing some of those so there are some free ones available on a website on a website called shl i know they're there because i've seen them but they are quite tricky
被撕成碎片的情况，我们说的事情是不真实的。你知道，我们想要保持在我们的能力范围内，并对我们所说的和所做的事情保持准确。但谈论你所做的保密性质的客户工作是可以的，这证明了为什么你将成为一名伟大的心理学家，以及为什么你现在是一名伟大的、尚未获得资格的心理学家。接下来，如果你申请的大学确实有选拔测试，它们可能是逻辑推理测试，也可能是情境判断测试，那么你能开始考虑计划和练习其中的一些吗？有一些免费的测试可以在一个名为SHL的网站上找到。我知道它们在那里，因为我看到过，但它们很难
to find so um if you want to check out the details on the show notes it will take you right there you can look at the example ones um but if you actually want to take some yourself you will need to register and i believe you need to register a new email address each time if you want to do multiple attempts. There's also another way that you can practice tests. You can get some for free through a website called assessmentday.co.uk. And there are details in the show notes. What that has is free resources available where you can practice and where it scores you and gives you your score there is also an opportunity to be able to pay and access more tests too and there's an exclusive coupon code available for my audience
找到。所以，如果你想查看节目说明中的详细信息，它会直接带你到那里。你可以查看示例，但如果你想亲自参加测试，你需要注册。我相信如果你想多次尝试，每次都需要注册一个新的电子邮件地址。还有另一种练习测试的方法。你可以通过一个名为assessmentday.co.uk的网站免费获得一些测试。节目说明中有详细信息。它有免费资源，你可以练习，它会为你评分并给出分数。也有机会付费访问更多测试，并且为我的听众提供了一个独家优惠券代码，
of aspiring psychologists and the code you will need to get 30% off is ASPIREPSYCH, all in upper caps, A-S-P-I-R-E-P-S-Y-C-H. And I did the situational judgment test and thought that it was a useful test and kind of useful to know what sort of score I was getting. So do check that out with that coupon code ASPIREPSYCH which is exclusive to my audience. Last but not least if you wanted to get a feel on all of the areas that I have covered, the research, the talking about yourself, the formulation, the learning different skills and strengths and thinking about tests tests then have you considered coming on board to the aspiring psychologist membership because this is what we do this is what we do well and i can also answer your questions very much in the way that i do within the free q a but with more
即有抱负的心理学家们。你需要获得30%折扣的代码是ASPIREPSYCH，全部大写，A-S-P-I-R-E-P-S-Y-C-H。我做了情境判断测试，认为这是一个有用的测试，了解我得到了什么样的分数很有用。所以请务必使用那个独家优惠券代码ASPIREPSYCH查看一下。最后但同样重要的是，如果你想了解我所涵盖的所有领域，包括研究、谈论自己、构思、学习不同的技能和优势以及思考测试，那么你是否考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家”会员资格？因为这就是我们所做的，这是我们擅长的。我也可以像在免费问答中那样回答你的问题，但有更多
time and sometimes face to face do on our zooms. So every week we have lunch with Marianne where I answer your questions. And if you haven't asked me any questions, I think with you more broadly about other concepts that are going on currently. But yeah, it's £30 a month. It's no minimum commitment. You can leave any time. And people find it's really, really useful in helping them develop their skills and their confidence so do please think about coming on board if you do enjoy the podcast and you aren't in a position where you're able to or want to join the membership please do consider making a donation buying me a cup of herbal tea via the donation option which is on my link it says say thanks and support me by donating so this podcast does cost me a few hundred pounds a month to put together so if you've valued any of the content any donation
时间，有时在我们的Zoom上是面对面的。所以每周我们都有“与Marianne共进午餐”，我会回答你的问题。如果你没有问我任何问题，我会和你更广泛地思考目前正在进行的其他概念。是的，每月30英镑。没有最低承诺。你可以随时离开。人们发现这在帮助他们发展技能和自信方面真的非常有帮助。所以如果你喜欢这个播客，并且你目前无法或不想加入会员，请务必考虑捐款，通过我链接上的捐款选项给我买一杯花草茶。上面写着“说声谢谢并捐款支持我”。这个播客每月确实花费我几百英镑来制作，所以如果你觉得任何内容有价值，任何捐款
that you might be willing to make is so greatly appreciated because the costs do come out of my own pocket and yeah that's it from me that's it today as ever if you've got anything you'd like me to talk about in the podcast then do go along to www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast and fill in your details on the form there to let me know whilst you're there why not leave me an audio testimonial either for the podcast or for any of the three books the grief collective the aspiring psychologist collective and the clinical psychologist collective heck if you're a member for the membership you could leave me one there too thank you so much and i hope this content is really useful i love providing it for you but
你愿意做出的贡献都将受到极大的赞赏，因为成本确实是我自己承担的。是的，这就是我今天要说的。一如既往，如果你有什么想让我在播客中谈论的内容，请访问www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/podcast，并在表格中填写你的详细信息告诉我。当你在那里时，为什么不给我留下一个音频推荐呢？无论是针对播客还是针对这三本书：《悲伤集体》（The Grief Collective）、《有抱负的心理学家集体》和《临床心理学家集体》。嘿，如果你是会员，你也可以在那里给我留一个。非常感谢，我希望这些内容真的很有用。我喜欢为你提供这些内容，但
as i said any donation that you can afford is so gratefully received. Thanks for being part of my world. And I will look forward to catching up with you for our next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, which will be coming to you from 6am on Monday. Thank you again. Take care. Be kind to yourself if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne With Dr. Mary Andrews My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner.
正如我所说，任何你负担得起的捐款都将受到极大的欢迎。感谢你成为我世界的一部分。我期待在下一期《有抱负的心理学家》播客中与你相见，节目将于周一早上6点发布。再次感谢。保重。如果你想成为一名心理学家，请善待自己，让这成为你的指南，让这个播客陪伴在你身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家》，我是Marianne博士。我是Jana，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。
I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，没有完美的途径可以成为一名临床心理学家。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你感到安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。